for e.g now i'm nancy o'dell  feel like that spark that tingle i feel  so lucky so i have to say i've been  wanting to kiss you for a while  about time andy and marcus sitting in a  tree but there's big drama coming there  are a few guys that have said that  i'm pissed i really am that is such a  dagger  the guys go at it confronting andrew  what is he hiding we're all here for the  right reasons and we want to make sure  that you are i'm not going to engage in  this sorry so that's the kind of guy you  are huh andrew it's like are you  seriously doing this  it's your own actions that showed who  you are as a person if you don't think  this is real then the door is right  there because this is so real to me  every single day this is